yeah so so as mentioned today we're
going to dive into a very interesting
topic
uh which is basically on machine
learning security uh so we're going to
talk a little bit about that uh just a
bit about myself my name is alejandra
sauced i'm engineering director at
selden technologies it's a machine
learning deployment and monitoring
startup we have one of the most popular
open source projects
for machine learning deployment in
kubernetes i'm chief science at the
institute for ethical ai which is a
research center that focuses on
developing frameworks for responsible ml
and governing member
at large
at the acm which is
a sort of public private body for
computer scientists um and yeah so as i
mentioned a couple of times as people
were coming in uh some of the resources
for the talk you can find them uh in the
in this repo
so this is going to be quite a practical
um
talk so i want to not just show you a
bunch of slides but give you some
practical examples and the way that i
wanted to do that
is to show you about and tell you about
security in machine learning with some
practical examples of machine learning
gone wrong
and what are some of the potential
challenges that may be introduced may
introduce security flaws at each stage
of the machine learning life cycle so
the repo contains some floor ml examples
that we're going to try to cover in this
session uh it also has a link to the
slides and link to other relevant
resources if you want further reading
so let's talk about security challenges
in machine learning so
the interesting thing about security in
machine learning is that it's not as
defined and explored as you would expect
similar to what we have seen in software
engineering in devops there's a lot of
practical frameworks that can be
adopted uh as well as some um
understanding of what are the main area
the main potential security
vulnerabilities at different stages and
there's a lot of resources on
machine learning applied to security
right like things like malware detection
or spam filters etc etc but what about
security in machine learning so in this
session we're going to be taking a
similar approach that was taken in those
other fields try to identify the key
challenges of security in machine
learning but also acknowledging that
it's impossible to make systems like
completely uh you know without
vulnerabilities or completely unhackable
right uh but what we can do is we can
mitigate undesired uh outcomes and we
can identify those critical or high
potential vulnerabilities that actually
need to be addressed as opposed to you
know try the impossible which is like
making a system completely uh
fully out of vulnerabilities which which
would be impossible and the solutions
will not just be technical and they will
be technical in nature
but ultimately they will still rely on
humans and process right so that's the
key thing and we're going to be
presenting it under the umbrella of this
concept of ml secops so there's already
a concept of secops security operations
as well as dev secops
so this is ultimately kind of like a
consortium of all of those different
components so identifying the best
practices in the intersection of
machine learning infrastructure
devops developer operations and
automation as well as security policies
so that's kind of an angle that we're
going to be taking today because this is
a python conference we're going to be
actually covering a little bit more of
the python and we're going to be
covering a little bit less of the
infrastructure
but as i'm going to reference later i
have other deep dives on you know
different
audiences like kubecon which is going to
be more on the infrastructure side
so there is also a lot of content that
we can rely on right there's a lot of
great research and great resources that
have already done the hard work of
identifying some best some potential
areas of of relevance uh specifically in
this in the software world right so this
is the uh ow asp which is the open web
uh
sort of like project uh for security and
they have this very famous uh sort of
resource which is the top 10
vulnerabilities that they release pretty
much every year and you know i'm not
going to go in detail right now but you
will see that this top 10
vulnerabilities we're going to come back
to them and we're going to see which are
the flood machine learning
vulnerabilities that we can map into
into into this awasp like the os ones
and today's talk is not going to be
covering the whole spectrum of machine
learning right like we we're going to be
just talking about machine learning
security so so it has to be a little bit
kind of like succinct and we have to
like you know look over a lot of the
more complex parts but what we are going
to be doing under the hood is we're
going to be taking a machine learning
model and you know hopefully like a lot
of you already have exposure to some
some kind of machine learning training
even if it's like the hello worlds like
the iris classifier uh which we're going
to be using um and we're going to be
deploying this model so actually taking
the ac the model that has been trained
as its binary i'm exposing it and
putting it as a running microservice as
a service that listens to requests and
provides responses the request would be
the prediction input the response is the
output so so we're going to actually
like you know identify what are the
potential flaws at the different parts
of this machine learning life cycle so
the training the the the deployment the
packaging the the monitoring et cetera
et cetera if you want to get a little
bit more detail so this is the tldr this
talk is going to be tldr on the machine
learning deployment if you do want to
actually delve into what is happening uh
there's talks linked in this uh slides
that you can that you can use uh so that
you see that it's not like just so hand
wavy and magical
there's some resources behind this um
and what we're going to be doing is
we're going to first train this machine
learning model and we're going to deploy
it using this tool called seldom core
this is the tool that allows us to
convert our binaries or our python code
into a fully fledged microservice our
machine learning model to a fully
fledged microservice so let's actually
do that
so let's take a cycle learn model with
the iris uh data set right so that's
basically
uh you know the usual hello world of
machine learning we're going to train
our logistic regression model we're
going to fit that logistic regression
model and we're going to test so we run
a prediction the prediction is an input
of a you know flower and an iris and it
predicts you know what class it will
fall under
we're going to then actually take this
model that we've trained and we're going
to persist that model because we need to
deploy it right somehow we need to say
let's save the model and then let's put
it inside of the microservice so we're
going to actually pickle this model
we're going to see what's inside we can
see that there's actually the logistic
regression class so this is how python
knows how to like recreate it let's
actually copy it into a google bucket s3
right just a remote bucket that then we
can deploy using selden right so we now
have deployed this model the way that it
works is
there is a container that runs in
kubernetes that hand wavy magic
the container itself pulls the artifact
and serves it right that's all we need
to know it's a micro service with an end
point that if we send a request it gives
us a response the same thing that we saw
in our predict function we are seeing
here great we have a model deployed easy
simple
and we're ready to go uh you know home
because
the work is done right high accuracy
model is running in production
you know that's that's where the life
cycle of the model finishes
unfortunately that's not the case right
and we know that with the different
stages of the machine learning life
cycle what we have done is you know
process the data
train the model persist the model deploy
the model and serve it right so the
challenge is now we need to ask the
question what are the security uh what
are the areas that actually are uh
at high risk of potential security
vulnerabilities and the only places that
are at high risk of security
vulnerability are the parts in red
right so basically everything
right and we're going to actually talk a
little bit about that
we're going to talk a little bit about
different parts of security risk and
machine learning we're going to talk
about the risks in loading model
artifacts
on accessing on on people getting access
to the model or the or the endpoints of
the model the challenges of the
dependencies of the artifact and the
servers the vulnerabilities in your code
of your of your actual model
uh the the the vulnerabilities of the
images and then some honorable mentions
because i only have 25 minutes
and i cannot cover all of the stuff and
you know even if i had like 45 minutes i
wouldn't be able to cover all of this
stuff because it's just so much so the
first part who loves pickles we all love
pickles we know what pickles are pickles
are the way in which python is able to
like dump a binary and reload it in a
different environment you know who else
loves pickles machine learning
practitioners they love pickles they use
pickles like there's not tomorrow and
there and i mean and there's a lot of
best practices that now moving away into
more sort of like robust realizations
methods but we're going to see how uh
this actually becomes a challenge with
with with uh the security areas of
pickles so let's actually load that that
that model that we just trained right so
this was basically stored as a pickle
that's what we deployed we're gonna just
reload it into python memory we we now
reloaded it into this model safe right
we run the prediction model safe still
works
now we're going to do an injection into
this pickle right we're going to take
that function that python runs to
understand how to load the pickle which
is this reduce function
we're going to then inject it into that
model itself this could be run like
somewhere else you know i don't know
where like you know it could be run
without the data scientist knowing the
model still behaves correctly you can
still run inference but the only
challenge is that when you actually save
that model what you save is actually
something different right so what are we
saving here we're saving uh you know
this this rubbish whatever it is
uh for sort of like showing this is just
going to copy your local environment and
put it in a file called
pond.txt right and we're just going to
show that this actually can run anything
right like what i can show is you can
actually pull the kubernetes secrets and
store them in a file or you can pull the
kubernetes secrets and send them into a
remote server you can do whatever you
want you can serve like a like a like a
ssh
session that you can connect you can you
can do quite a lot of things so we're
going to now actually copy that artifact
we're going to deploy that artifact into
that unsafe model so now it's running
right there's nothing wrong because it
just loaded it into memory but if we not
look at that container we can see that
the pawn.txt file was created if we
actually load it locally right we can
see that there's no pawn.txt file
locally if we load that model locally we
can see that now it creates that
pawn.txt file right so so this is just
basically saying like you know the
pawn.txt doesn't like you know kill your
computer but you can actually do
whatever you want so that actually shows
some challenges and the problem is like
what i said a lot of machine learning
practitioners and a lot of like very
very uh you know high profile frameworks
use this right so uh major frameworks
like scikit-learn pytorch they actually
have especially i can learn they
actually tell you this is the way that
you actually save a model right and the
challenge is that there's also
exploration okay how do we how do we
solve this right do we have do we create
some sort of like super intelligence
super smart code scan python scan pixel
scan
libraries that just like check for
malicious code and the actual
recommendation is no
right when it comes to pickles and when
it comes to just you know running code
even if it's containers it comes into a
trust or discard mechanism right you
either have a mechanism in which you can
ensure that the the artifacts that you
that you're retrieving are legit uh you
know irrespective of whether they are
you know pickles or or not i mean of
course if you can avoid using pickles
that's even better because they are
dependent on the python environment and
there are you know tons of other issues
that pickles bring that you know are
well beyond just security but
there are some considerations to make
sure that it is more of that trust and
discard perspective right as opposed to
trying to bring in some sort of like
although there could be some value of
exploring some sort of code scans there
are there are some frameworks that that
do provide that uh which are pretty
interesting and i do recommend checking
out but
that is just some key consideration and
as as we go through the talk we're going
to be mentioning some of these touch
points throughout the cicd pipelines
your etl pipelines your you know data
science human workflows that actually
benefit from having this trust or
discard mechanisms you need to make sure
that there is a trust
by design process within the different
phases of your machine learning system
and you know maybe this doesn't make
sense when you're just like a team of
data scientists who are responsible for
the serving of your models this may not
make sense if you're just one data
scientist who's responsible of just
their jupiter notebook and their serving
of their model but this makes sense when
you have like multiple business units
with data scientists that produce models
that then are
you know connected into uh pipelines
through machine learning engineers and
then actually monitored by devops teams
right so that's where it kind of like
starts making sense uh for that now
second second part this is the kind of
like you know
sexier part of the machine learning
security the one that like everybody
talks about but you know we don't see us
as as much in the world and this is
what can you do when you have access to
the model endpoint or artifact and this
is where the concept of adversarial
security comes in so adversarial
security is the ability to be able to
take a model
and try to ask the question how can i
fool this model
and how can i fool this model whilst
fooling a human as well right so from
this example these are some set of
images for the c410 classifier that
classifies you know one of the ten
images or actually uh i think it may be
one of the slightly larger ones uh data
sets uh but yeah so you can see that
like these are pictures of a horse of a
truck and a dog and after being run
through an adversarial uh um
sort of
example to create an adversarial example
um you can see that the picture of a
horse with um you know undetectable
human
eye you wouldn't be able to know what
actually makes this suddenly a dog right
or that truck and automoba or that dog a
horse right so this is basically the
ways in which you can actually modify an
example uh in order for you to be able
to provide uh that uh capability of
fooling a model as well as the human
that looks at it and this is interesting
because
ultimately this means that if you just
give access to the endpoint of a machine
learning model without actually the
respective uh you know
monitoring or logging to understand that
there may be some malicious intent to
reverse engineer in some way or another
the behavior the internal behavior of
the model then you may end up in a
situation where um yeah people can
exploit that right and i have you know
again an example that shows basically
hands-on how you can create this
adversar
adversarial examples but yeah for the
you know perspective of time i'm not
going to be able to dive into it but you
will have you know more than more than
more than the ability to to dive into it
yourself
so
the the third thing is is to just
emphasize that um you know once once you
actually
are able to detect that you need to
guard your potential model for
adversarial attacks you can introduce
things like adversarial detectors so we
actually at seldom have a library called
alibi detect that provides some
state-of-the-art algorithms where you
can leverage
some of these adversarial detection
mechanisms so it allows you to run this
uh you know detector in front of your
model such that whenever a prediction
comes in you can actually you know ask
the question is it an adversarial
malicious uh example
the challenge is that if somebody
actually has access to the model
artifacts itself they may be able to
find examples that can fool not only the
model but also the detector right and
the challenge is also once you somebody
has access to the model there are some
challenges of not just being able to
fool the model itself but to be able to
extract insights from the model itself
so this is an interesting piece of
research that talks about extracting
training data from large language models
so and there are some some machine
learning models that actually require
having the data you know with with the
model itself to be able to like perform
the inference so those are just some
some things uh that you have to take
into consideration you know if you if
you uh perhaps break this kind of like
best practice in some of the parts of
your pipeline you may be exposed to some
of these potential challenges
okay number three dependencies so the
challenge is python python provides a
lot of you know nuances when it comes to
dependencies i'm sure anyone that is
that has maintained a python library for
more than a year wouldn't know about
this one day you go home and everything
works correctly the next day you come
back and your ci tests are failing you
try to figure out why and like a fourth
level dependency
you know got updated and the third level
dependency package didn't pin it even
though you pinned all of your
dependencies and you know welcome to pip
right um so uh the challenge with you
know the the the uh python sort of
dependency management is that
you know this is not something that like
out of the box you're gonna be able to
like look and you do need to make sure
that this is a security consideration
because there can be a potential third
fourth fifth twentieth level dependency
that may have been updated with some
malicious malware that may affect you
and we have seen a lot of examples which
i'm going to talk a little bit about uh
of how they are uh provided so you know
here i have some examples where you know
we can show uh you know some of the
dependencies how like you know with pip
pip depth tree you can see that
scikit-learn actually pulls some
third-level dependencies you can use
other tools like poetry uh i don't know
who here has heard about poetry raise
your hands nice okay you're all in the
good practice um yeah so support through
basically creates a poetry.log file
which is almost equivalent but not
really as doing a pip freeze into into a
lock into a requirements.txt file but
yeah so basically this allows you to
create uh you know a complete sort of
look of your python environment you know
disclaimer this is just your python
environment right this is not your
entire you know linux non-python
dependencies which are the thing that
we're going to cover
in a bit
um so
um yeah and this is this is challenging
because we have actually seen
well-intended uh well-intended uh
actions that actually have raised some
ethical questions or uh
but that actually reflect the
introduction of of of of code that will
potentially affect any development
library that depends on that specific
library right so this is not something
that is like completely unheard of that
never happens so it's something to
actually you know be conscious of so i
think that that's one thing to mention
um and i think yeah i have one more
thing to mention so uh there are some
some libraries that are also kind of
like improving kind of like the
infrastructure so emil flo you know
there's actually some some really great
talks at this conference on another flow
we've actually been doing some
collaboration with our python machine
learning server called ml server
so we actually tackle some of those
dependency
hell
challenges
through the introduction of conda pack
where we actually are able to like dump
kind of like a froze freeze of the
environment that then the actual micro
service can can load it and then using
stuff like poetry so that we can
actually have a complete reproducible
environment the thing with with conda
pack is that it's actually you know it's
kind of you have more than just python
right like you can install java i mean
for good or for bad right i mean for for
some some challenges and there are other
things that that you can leverage for
dependency scans so you can actually use
things like um you know
open source frameworks like safety check
which actually checks all of your
dependencies validates whether there are
uh dependencies that have
vulnerabilities dependencies that are
actually potentially too
uh uh you know old etc etc so so yes i
mean i think i think you know you'll
have enough time to cover that on on
your own site uh code scanning is also
important making sure that you don't
have like bad practices on your code
itself uh we know that there are some
potential code vulnerabilities that have
now been removed in in frameworks like
tensorflow right like you they actually
had like import from yaml we know i mean
if you remember there was a massive
vulnerability with yamo uh with the with
the load uh uh uh unsafe um that you
know could be exploited and any
framework that had that like was was
actually uh reminiscent of that and
ultimately codes can't allow you to like
avoid those those things and you know
you can check the code scan example uh
which basically shows you some like
potential vulnerability areas
and you know
one thing to just like bear in mind is
that jupiter notebooks are no different
right that's still code uh until you
know once they grow to a certain level
so that's that's something to take into
consideration image scanning another
important thing you know making sure
that you scan your containers for cves
and update the internal dependencies and
some honorable mentions making sure that
you actually have your encryption for
data artifacts at rest and in transit
authentication authorization and
infrastructure hiring there's some
really good resources that you can check
out there
again we talked about the ow asp
standards these are the flood machine
learning equivalents uh you know uh i
i'd love to go into a bit more detail
but you know you will actually like be
able to see it uh in more detail so this
is you know also kind of like a bit of a
pun the fml equivalent and you know i i
i work hard to you know get get that
acronym uh
to work uh but yeah so this is actually
quite interesting and we're gonna be
working on standardizing them a bit
further so yeah so the anatomy
production ml we've been able to like
talk about the training the ci cd the
deployment we've been able to also like
mention some of the different personas
the data scientists the machine learning
engineer devops engineer
and you know some further resources that
you will be able to find on the repo
and then as a reminder the reasons for
the talk are on the ethical ml slash
mfml security uh you know repository
where you'll find all of this right
you'll be able to run it yourself you'll
be able to try it and if you don't like
something you'll be able to submit a pr
because
open source is great and with that thank
you very much and i think we are on just
on time hopefully
[Applause]
yeah yeah thanks you were even a bit
faster
so again um please feel free to ask
questions on slido um i don't see one
yet so i will start
do you think that um
the security in ml is reflected in
on the customer side as well so
is this something that there's a concern
or that the customer is willing to pay
for
or what is your opinion on that
yeah that's a great question um so i
would say to specifically your question
yes absolutely like they are like you
know security is is their last name
right but they're clueless absolutely
clueless and i just know that because
putting together this talk
emphasize how little resources there is
there's a lot about machine learning for
security but not about security
secure machine learning
so yeah
okay great uh then there's a question
from stefan
have you ever run into problems with
fixed and conflicting package pinning
have i run into an issue of like uh sort
of configuration management of
dependency pinning i believe that yes
yes yes oh absolutely yeah yeah i mean
you could hear the pain in my voice when
i was talking about that we actually had
like uh we've had several we've actually
had several like um you know the one i
remember from the top of my head is like
i remember azure updated their framework
um so like you know three like always
like 20
major versions above and that just broke
like yeah half of the libraries out
there because tons of them actually had
that dependency for some weird reason
and it was like a yeah like a third
fifth level dependency and we've also
run into this issue when uh addressing
cves right like you you try to like pin
something and then you know a second
level third level may have some some
issues as well so that's why we just
moved to poetry
okay great and then there's another
question could you elaborate on how you
may be able to detect an adversarial
attack with alibi
yeah for sure yeah yeah well so so
there's actually like a an end-to-end
example a jupiter notebook that guides
you with a
c410 data set um so probably that would
that would cover it in more in more
depth but the way that i would say is
that the other cell detector would
actually try to get um the you know
input of the that is coming into the
model and try to like see how feasible
that is for actually going into the
model itself based on the probabilities
of the output so that would actually
like work in tandem with the model
so it's quite an interesting area area
of research so i recommend check it out
okay great
are there other questions i think and
thank you for your time thank you for
the amazing talk awesome round thank you